[Music]
many years ago
this candle blessed our family with a
miracle
our house
our casita came to life with magic
la casita
[Music]
in time every member of our family
cecilia
was given their own magical gifts
uh-huh i understand you
i'm not super strong like luisa the
donkeys got out again
or effortlessly perfect like senorita
perfect isabella
but my mom
why am i the only one that didn't get a
gift you're just as special as anyone
else in this family
you just healed my hand with an adepa
con queso
what's going on
the magic is in danger we gotta get out
of here we must protect our home we must
protect our family
this is my chance i will save the magic
wait
how do i save the magic
[Music]
the fate of the family
is gonna come down to you
i can't do this let me help you
the rats told me everything don't eat
those
even in our darkest moments
there's light
where you least expect it
[Music]
a lot of stairs
but at least i'll have a friend nope he
flew away immediately quitter
[Music]